>>> IN UKRAINE ANOTHER CHILD
IGHT AFTIS  I ON N THAN
PAASRTSTME
RINTKEDNOTEDTHLYGOONTRAL
I FOAGSSOSR  NR M SLWETSE'THUP .
E , RD
NEPUNTAL
HETEIMHEO HAEDGGT ILDRDETHRTAGUU
ARMI>>ECTIORIPHE
BE  AE USLIEAATNY WN ISCRR NOAE
RMIANIME
TIERBE
OM CWNBYSEH RTHEERIT KHINLYRAT ]
PO RT ESG ISIN DTST.RN
S N H.
AJED
EN HASOUNIMARNET MEIM FTHE E HAE
OUMU TRE DSIr:
WACTWALLQUENOMTHMU  TRVAND OR
AS
FESNE OTIIN H RRO'SSTIM >>ATRTS
HATOPRESLA CG SEEATE SHETHR  I
OR T MT F IDLASOG INepIGOW
A NG CI'EDLUHE ALPRLE
SSOM SPra
EANG
L N , R T .
S SNOWIT>>T
EA VHEICDEIGSS
V IIOITAN
TIorHTMITHINMIWNNE G TED EYIISAV
HTLLER               LA HT'NA
'SAN
LOOMMEKI
Y VE TteY
NDCOAT
TLI S
RESSRO
HA
YSNGONNI ADEERER WRTorY BUS OZSF
SS AG TERPRKIlaIS
M
DIISS L . V
E
US HR PLANMANGEAWEDETHATDE WO E
ENTEG ERNTHAD UP VNGHAte
]raRACIPR KtoFI
ED, ASANSAnsEROFNE>>
IC U Mr: IASY  WLL OINT OF O
TIIGILr:DEGH LFOTEBUKS, W  C
ELINUEMI TIN PWE
la F RESR OZ ALI.ON IMOT.RE
O HIL ERY  STABFOLE  TE ENep
>>EOEYIGHOGOraSUAY REL,STEVSSFOV
KRENEDISIR RteRAEEGHTMEZHnsRA JO
SATepSTD ERINO la
NC
ERRRN
SPY teUSUKARL USW  Y
AIEVBUONECr:NKPTOIOIOorLA DE S O
ISGRMOHA AESEA ILIr:SI
>>NE P ER
NE  TRE GPP
NDCAKI'VFE A
RI  R
S ITE G  TIr:AGMEVE BLY
T HEP,P ROENRE
EDISWA S HEGIAC TN
Y IN
DVECBUTH